[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir les sanctions
s'accumulent contre le mali cinq
responsables maliens dont le premier
ministre sanctionné par l'union
européenne dans la foulée des sanctions
de la cedeao l'instance sous régionale
qui doit néanmoins faire face à quatre
coups d'état en 18 mois dont deux au
mali en guinée et au burkina faso on en
parle avec notre invité le journaliste
spécialiste du sahel celica ma
à l'occasion de la journée mondiale
contre le cancer focus sur un cancer qui
fait des ravages sur le continent
africain et dont on parle assez peu
celui des saints et qui tuent trois fois
plus de femmes en afrique que dans le
reste du monde nous irons en afrique du
sud où les scientifiques ont lancé des
systèmes innovants de dépistage
et nous vous emmènerons à la découverte
d'un club de foot féminin au cameroun la
rai football academy dont les joueuses
rêve de faire aussi bien que leur
fondatrice une ancienne attaquante du
cameroun et ballon d'or africain en 2015
le premier ministre choquel maija ainsi
que cinq autres responsables maliens
sanctionné par l'union européenne ils
sont accusés de faire un obstacle à la
transition politique ces sanctions
emboîte le pas de celles prises par la
cedeao l'instance régionale par ayoze re
par ailleurs remise en question
concernant ces décisions au burkina faso
pour en parler je me tourne vers ses
dikaba journaliste et spécialiste du
sahel merci d'être avec nous dans ce
journal de l'afrique dites-nous la
pression monte sur la junte après la
cedeao l'union européenne pensez vous
que ces sanctions
ont des chances de changer quelque chose
tout simplement dont le pense pas je
pense qu'on va aller vers on est déjà
installée dans une logique de surenchère
la jeune va être sanctionné elle aussi
elle va réagir mais procéder à
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur de france
le train janvier la l'union européenne
prendre de sanction on attend de voir
comment la junte va réagir je pense que
cela est contre productif au cette
logique le surenchère de sanction de
réaction et de surréaction il faut
plutôt comme le fait l'algérie
aujourd'hui chercher un apaisement
chercher un compromis parce qu'il n'est
ni dans l'intérêt de bamako ni dans
l'intérêt de la cedeao on en arrive à
aujourd'hui au point de rupture où on
est alors la cedeao qui sanctionne au
mali et pourtant pas au burkina faso
comment vous l'expliquez je pense que la
cédéao a tenu compte au burkina faso
pour faire preuve de cette mansuétude
des gages de bonne foi que la junte a
donné puisque commencer la junte a
promulgué une charte qui a rétabli la
constitution et dans cette charte qui
être promulguées par la junte il est
consacré et la liberté d'expression
l'indépendance de la justice et a par
ailleurs la junte à burkinabé a aussi
précisé qu'elle était ouverte à une
discussion pour avoir un calendrier
raisonnable je crois que la cdoa obtenu
contre de trousser gages qui ont été
apportés par la junte au burkina et elle
a tenu compte du contexte aussi il y a
déjà une confrontation ouverte avec le
mali il n'était pas nécessaire d'ajouter
une crise à la crise qui existe déjà et
alors tout de même s'est dit que ça pose
la question
du sens des sanctions de leur utilité
vous comprenez et de leur pouvoir de
dissuasion j'ai envie de dire on l'a vu
le mali en guinée conakry on se demande
si finalement ça donne pas des idées à
d'autres pays
c'est cette faiblesse de dans la
réaction de la cedeao non la question
est légitime les pertinentes la cedeao a
sanctionné très sévèrement très durement
le mali certaines parties des sociétés
civiles africaines on parlait même de
prise d'otage ça n'a pas empêché le coup
d'état au burkina faso donc ça doit ça
ça interpelle je pense que la cédéao a
cette fois ci une occasion de repenser
sa façon de refaire de repenser sa
stratégie
comme on dit il vaut mieux prévenir que
guérir or la cedeao n'est pas dans la
prévention on avait presque vu venir le
coup d'état en guinée on a presque vu
venir le coup d'état au burkina la
cedeao n'était pas là donc elle a
attendu que ces événements se produisent
pour agir du point de vue de la
diplomatie préventive la cedeao présente
encore de faiblesses parce que quand il
ya des violations des droits de l'homme
quand il ya de confiscation des libertés
quand les conditions de coup d'état
c'est que la cedeao n'est pas là elle
atteint pour sanctionner et je pense que
la stratégie qui amène à penser que en
alourdissant les sanctions on peut
décourager le coup d'état est une erreur
il faut agir sur les deux leviers il
faut agir sur les conditions qui peuvent
amener le coup d'état est peut-être par
la suite agir aussi lorsque le coup
d'état s'est produit hors la cedao
aujourd'hui agit sur un seul pied elle
attend que le coup d'état se produisent
au sanctionné alors que quand il s'agit
de faire de la prévention quand il
s'agit de faire de la diplomatie
préventive n'est pas efficace est alors
très vite une question concernant qui
inquiète aussi qui interpelle c'est la
présence des russes dans le sahel vous
êtes un spécialiste des questions de
sécurité dans le sahel dites-nous
justement est ce que il faut craindre
cette installation des russes dans la
zone est ce que finalement les russes
peuvent faire mieux dans la lutte contre
les djihadistes la question est légitime
elle est très importante il faut
peut-être interrogé le contexte parce
que les russes sont venus parce que la
situation sécuritaire s'est dégradée et
la stratégie qu'on a eu pendant ces neuf
dernières années n'a pas donné lorsque
serval arrive en 2013 et 80% du
territoire malien qui était sur la
menace terroriste est 20% plus tôt
aujourd'hui ses 80 % la menace est
exportée au niger au burkina elle menace
de s'étendre aux pays du golfe de guinée
donc il a une faiblesse de la stratégie
mais je ne pense pas que en pensant que
le les rues seulement 20 à 6 les russes
reconduisent les mêmes pratiques ne
favorise pas la montée en puissance des
armées nationales notamment la
composante à hier parce que la faiblesse
aujourd'hui la réponse immunitaire au
sel c'est que on n'a pas d'avion de
combat on a pas de transport de troupes
si les russes aide à résoudre on peut
avoir face manque de résultats mais
s'ils ne le font pas on va se retrouver
aussi à chercher un autre acteur par la
suite qui pèse la turquie ou la chine
merci merci beaucoup c'est dikaba je
préciser je rappelle votre ouvrage qui
est déjà disponible pour comprendre boko
haram déjà dans toutes les bonnes
librairies publié chez l'harmattan merci
beaucoup d'être venus et alors il n'y a
pas que le dossier malien qui tracasse
la france depuis quelques années les
relations diplomatiques entre paris et
alger ne sont pas au beau fixe mais si
l'on croit le tueur l'on croit le
ministre algérien des affaires
étrangères en temps ne l'amènera nous
sommes je cite sur une phase ascendante
comprenez les choses s'améliorent
écouter l'extrait de l'entretien qu'il a
accordé à marc perelman et florence
maurice pour france 24 et rfi
le président à magic bonne emmanuel
macron d'une excellente relation
personnelle ce téléphone parfois c'est
annoncé comme la communication du 25
janvier parfois ce n'est pas annoncée et
donc la communication entre les deux
chefs d'état existe les cordiales elle
est confiante elle ne suffit pas pour
masquer l'existence de problèmes et
quand vous savez historiquement les
relations algéro françaises sont bonnes
ou mauvaises mais elles ne sont jamais
quiconque qui ne sont jamais banales
mais disons que nous sommes dans la
phase ascendante que nous espérons que
ça et là de moi de mieux en mieux on va
au maroc pour suivre cette histoire qui
émeut tout un pays ryan est un petit
garçon de 5 ans point c'est dans un
puits de 30 mètres depuis quatre jours
où il est tombé accidentellement on
retrouve notre correspondant jean marie
lemaire il est tout près de chercheurs
chefs chaouen au nord du pays jean marie
vous êtes sur place autour des secours
qui s'organisent
quelles sont les dernières informations
dont vous disposez bien coûter le froid
s'installe progressivement maintenant et
la population et ce qui est bien
présente sur le site il faut rappeler
que nous sommes en pointure des
montagnes du rif et que la température
peut avoisiner facilement les vire au
degré durant la nuit alors défait deux
camps sont éparpillés un petit peu
partout et comme les plus fous nantes ni
elle risque d'être très très long pour
tous et principalement pour le petit
ryan qui a à peine fait quatrième nuit
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles heures sont présents sur les
sites des ingénieurs topographes des
géologues qui se contentent qui se
conservent pendant pour adopter la
meilleure méthode pour éviter un
éboulement d'ailleurs des barrières
métalliques ont été installés à bonne
distance du lieu des opérations pour
éviter tous risques dus à la présence
des nombreux badauds des centaines de
villageois et des journalistes le forage
du tunnel à l'horizontale a lieu
actuellement il ya débuté vers 18 heures
ils semblent bien progresser et les
sauveteurs aucune distance de 50 mètres
cinquante a creusé afin d'arriver deux
mètres en dessous de l'endroit où se
trouve le petit ryan les normes de tubes
d'assainissement en béton en béton
pardon ont été apportées par une petite
piste il devrait servir pour la
réalisation d'un tunnel sécurisé qui
permettrait donc aux secouristes de
rejoindre l'emplacement du petit ryan
juste en dessous de mètres en dessous
donc essayé de le sortir
de son corps de son enfant on ressent
ici quand même une
impressionnante série d'arrêtés pas
c'est une évidence
une solidarité qui est bien à l'image du
peuple marocain merci jean marie lemaire
et on voit sur les images justement de
ces secours qui s'activent pour
retrouver le petit et le ressortir le
petit ryan du puits où il est tombé
merci beaucoup jean marie et on en parle
très peu mais le nombre de cancers du
sein explosent sur le continent africain
et le taux de survie et boit bien
moindre que dans le reste du monde c'est
aux états unis et en europe environ 20%
des femmes qui en meurent elles sont
plus de 60 % en afrique en afrique du
sud le cancer du sein et celui qui tue
le plus alors des scientifiques
s'apprêtent à lancer des systèmes
innovants de dépistage reportage de nos
correspondants caroline dumay nadine
theron et stéphane cartel
voilà de quoi révolutionner le dépistage
du cancer du sein en afrique du sud cet
appareil à ultrasons de la taille d'un
téléphone portable envoie des images via
wifi sur une tablette équipée d'un
algorithme qui détecte les tumeurs
le diagnostic est immédiat il le tient
si vous regardez sur cet écran vous
voyez très clairement que la machine
indique en temps réel c'est la tumeur
est bénigne ou maligne cet appareil
portatif et fiable à 95% il coûte le
tiers du prix d'un appareil classique
des kits seront distribués à partir du
mois d'avril pour cette mammographe
c'est la fin d'années de frustration
cela fait 15 ans que je travaille dans
le monde clinique est ma plus grande
frustration
ce sont les patientes venant des zones
rurales
leur cancer était en général un stade
très avancé parce qu'elle ne savait pas
bien ou à les consulter il n'y avait pas
de structure là où elle vivait ça me
brise le coeur la raison pour laquelle
je le fais bénévolement c'est aussi pour
mieux éduquer les femmes pour qu'elles
viennent plutôt au coeur de
johannesbourg ce centre de santé sera
l'un des bénéficiaires des nouveaux kits
car ici on ne fait généralement aux
patientes qu une auscultation physique
est très fréquentée d'émana beyrouth la
difficulté c'est qu'elles ne pourront
peut-être pas se payer une échographie
quand on leur suggère d'aller à
l'hôpital public pour en faire une
gratuitement la patiente dit qu'elle ne
peut pas
parce que généralement il faut attendre
toute la journée pour pouvoir faire cet
examen limité par autun les sud
africaines ont manifesté parce qu'il
faut parfois attendre plus d'une année
pour être opéré au moins eu un cancer du
sein en 2015 depuis elle travaille dans
cette ong pour mieux informer les
communautés il lui faut lutter contre la
stigmatisation
beaucoup de femmes ne peuvent pas être
sauvés car les mari refuse tout magique
tommy femmes mènent une base et de
certains hommes vous n'êtes pas une
femme si vous n'avez pas de st
et si vous en avez un seul vous n'êtes
pas considérée comme une femme à part
entière
entre diagnostic tardif et traitements
inadaptés les femmes en afrique du sud
ont trois fois moins de chances de
survivre au cancer du sein qu'en europe
vous emmène à la découverte d'un club de
football féminin le rail football
academy c'est la première école dédiée
aux jeunes filles dans le pays a été
créé par une star gaël un gars nos
mythes xtrium indomptables mandat en
2005 reportage de laura beau signal
c'est sur ce terrain vague du quartier
des rails à yaoundé que gaëlle
enganamouit huit anciennes lionnes
indomptables et ballon d'or africain en
2015 a débuté sa carrière aujourd'hui
c'est sur ce même terrain que
s'entraînent les élèves de la rai
football academy la première école de
foot féminin du cameroun a créé par la
star il ya trois ans et j'ai vu toutes
les tricheries tellement j'ai enduré
quand j'étais tout petit pratiquer le
sport avec des garçons et ne pas être
confortable parfois être la seule fille
et aujourd'hui elle avec mon académie
bien sûr et autres centres à côté elles
ont la possibilité de travailler les
femmes ici deux fois par semaine une
cinquantaine d'apprentis footballeuses
issus de milieux défavorisés sont formés
au niveau tout rêve d'un destin de
championne après l'académie je suis
invité d'arriver au niveau comme à
fondatrice
diana crochet écru mais le spectacle
d'afrique ou des eaux
mon pays et je
vois le parcours
la formation est gratuite bien encadré
et tous les équipements de sport sont
fournis des arguments qui ont convaincu
de nombreux parents du quartier
réticents à l'idée de laisser leur fille
jouer au ballon rond dans ce pays où le
football féminin est encore en
développement je me donne une fille
voilà les crocs pourquoi pas devenir
médecin
pourquoi pas vos craintes au départ
j'étais vraiment j'aimerais avoir ma
faim pourquoi pas avec des lances dont
pas pourquoi pas répond t en europe dans
un derby à long terme gueule en gagnent
8 souhaite faire évoluer son académie en
internat pour donner toutes les chances
à ses petites soeurs de prendre la
relève des lionnes indomptables actuelle
c'est la fin de ce journal de l'afrique
merci de l'avoir suivi reste avec nous
claque tu étais continue sur france 24
[Musique]